états unis nous étions hambourg vous
savez hier et je crois que notre soirée
spéciale franco-allemande il manquait un
homme un autre célèbre hambourgeois karl
lagerfeld je vous l'avais promis
en fait le plus parisien des allemands
vit à paris depuis l'âge de 14 ans il y
est styliste dans une grande maison de
prêt-à-porter alors français-allemand
aujourd'hui une se pose guère la
question plus important pour lui que le
transfère le tracé d'une frontière
le dessin d'une ligne ou le choc des
couleurs chapeau demi-lune s'y colle
cratère pour vendre une griffe française
un styliste allemand et quand karl
lagerfeld décide une carte de l'europe
celle ci ressemble toujours à une femme
non
et je me considère comme un styliste du
mot couturier enfin petit monde et je
trouve et je sens qu'ils vont tuer les
selistes aujourd'hui ça me pose la
question urbaine suite les allemands je
vis de france est visé c'est des choses
de ce genre je me pose pas ces questions
là tu dirais aujourd'hui on a une
sensibilité européenne
peut-être qu'il ya 20 ans c'était
différent on avait une plus grande
sensation des petites phrases entre les
différents pays
quand je suis en france tu que j'avais
14 ans je voulais aller les couleurs
france était mon rêve depuis toujours
comme dès le départ j'avais après
l'anglais le français l'allemand donc il
n'y avait pas les problèmes de normes
moment là j'avais l'impression d'aller à
l'étranger
vous faites la france l'allemagne
l'italie surtout dans la mode
je veux alex müller mais l'ambiance est
quand même